hey everyone this is how to Hollywood
and I'm your host Kristen Gill and today
I have celebrity makeup artist
Lindsay Zavitz here with me hello tell
me what you're gonna do then I'm gonna
recreate the look I usually do on
Chrissy Teigen just that natural bronzy
glow a look with a nude lip a good set
of lashes and of course that highlight
you know we're doing that highlight
let's get started
we're gonna start with prepping the skin
so I'm just gonna use a little bit of a
moisturizer and I always like to apply
it with a brush but at home you can just
use your fingers just Chrissy have dry
skin or her skin it's pretty combination
it's pretty good it's pretty perfect
makeup really well it looks perfect so
when I do makeup I always start with the
eyes first so I'm going to put this on
this just kind of helps deep Hough and
if you're a little tired just that's
cool
and this kind of the eye shadow falls on
this but I take a makeup wipe anyways to
clean up any mess so I'm gonna start
with brows I use the Anastasia brow
palette the main color I use though is
taupe even though like your brows are
pretty dark but I like to fill them in
with a lighter color so they don't look
too dark brows are super important they
really frame the face I always do this I
always use a bronzer as the first color
that I put on the eyeshadow it acts as a
great transition color so I'm using the
Tom Ford's bronzer I'm just using a
little fluffy brush this is a morphe
brush and then now what I'm going to use
this is my new favorite product this is
the Tom Ford it's like a little duo on
the top is a little bit of a shimmer and
then on the bottom is a little cream
color I'm just gonna use a little Mac
brush okay just take a little bit out
and put it on my hand and I just start
right at the lash and kind of blend it
upwards so when did you start working
with Chrissy um probably about five
months ago or so Wow that's new yeah
pretty recent what's your favorite part
of working with Chrissy um she's just
really sweet and down-to-earth so really
easygoing so that always helps and she's
so pretty so you know any look you do
great I'm gonna yeah exactly it's gonna
look amazing you don't have to be too
careful when you're applying the cream
because I go over top with another
little blending brush and
lend that out and I kind of go in like
circular motion to blend it so you don't
get any creasing so I'm going to use a
smaller rounded brush this is the one
that I applied the bronzer with so I
always kind of go back and forth I'm
just gonna mix a couple of the colors
together and I start on the outer corner
and then just go right into the crease
and then I take that fluffy brush that I
applied the bronzer with and I go right
over top just to make sure it's all
blended because you don't want to see
where you started and stopped with the
eyeshadow so blending is key I always
say invest in a good set of makeup
brushes because you really can't get a
good eyeshadow look without you know
good brushes the right tools I'm just
gonna use my eyeliner favorite eyeliner
it's by Mac and it's called Teddy and I
always smudge it out with eyeshadow but
this look that I did on Chrissy I did
both I did the Teddy eyeliner and then I
did a little bit of a black eyeliner but
a lot of times my go-to is just this
eyeliner it's great for fall too
especially if you normally don't wear a
lot of makeup this is a good color then
I just take a dark brown eyeshadow and a
little blendy brush we go right over top
what's been your favorite looking
creating for Chrissy so far I would say
this one yeah yeah it's just it's kind
of like a soft smokey look because I
like more of like a natural glam yeah so
this is my favorite where you look done
up but it doesn't look too crazy and
like a lot of color on the eyes now I'm
gonna use a black eyeliner and I put it
right in the waterline so it's right
under the lashes what it does is makes
your lashes look fuller and darker
without seeing that harsh black eyeliner
and they just put a little bit right
over top of the brown eyeliner - and I
just take a black eyeshadow and a little
blending and it's a brush it's super
dense and so short and you just get
right into the lash root and smoke it
out a little bit more so now I'm gonna
take that eyeshadow from the Tom Ford
duo I just use my finger and close I add
a little bit of the shimmer on top of
the lid and it's not too much it's
really subtle but when you look down
it's really pretty you can see a little
bit of that iridescent sand twinkle and
it's gold too
so I'm gonna take these little guys off
you're just gonna take the Teddy
eyeliner I'm gonna put it on the bottom
right in the waterline I'm just a little
bit along the lash root and then blend
it out with eye shadow so I'm going to
use a strip lash my favorite strip
lashes are the Lily lashes these are the
mink ones and you can actually reuse a
few times so now I'm gonna put a little
bit of a primer um this is my all-time
favorite primer it's by Dermalogica and
it's called hydro polar primer I just
use a little bit and I just apply it
right on the t-zone
so with foundations I mix a few I never
just use one foundation I used the Mac
strobe cream my favorite foundation
right now the lemare I always apply
foundation with foundation brush and
then I just blend it out with a Beauty
Blender I'm going to use a little bit in
the Kevin Kwan and it's zero nine and
it's really pink as you can see so
whenever I use concealers I'd like to
use paint tones
I'm just dab a little bit right under
the eyes and then blend so for
concealers NARS is my favorite I'm gonna
use honey and custard so I'm gonna use
honey first and I'll just you to open
and look up and I just dab a little bit
right underneath the eye and I bring it
down a little bit so I'm going to use
this as a highlighter as well and then I
put custard right over top I'm gonna use
the Tom Ford cream bronzer
have you tried that before I have not
that I have seen it and I want it I use
intensity one if they have two different
colors
I like intensity one can I just use a
little this is a dose of color brush
apply this right under the cheekbone
then they just blend it out it doesn't
go muddy or it doesn't look too pain
what's wrong natural there's Christie
like a deep contour she does she loves
her contour but blended blending is key
nose contour
[Music]
so now I'm gonna set I'm gonna use the
lemare translucent powder and then the
Geo paunchy setting powder it's the pink
one so I always like to use key key
colors under the eyes and I'm just
taking a brush and dabbing a little bit
of the colors together both of these
powders have a little bit of an ear
death needs to them so I'm just taking a
fluffy brush a little all over I'm just
gonna go right over top of the cream
bronzer with a Tom Ford powder bronzer
I'm just using an angled brush so what's
your vibe when you're getting ready with
Christie do you guys listen to music or
was it kind of quiet and it's serene
really just depends on what we're doing
and where we are pretty going yeah
that's a bit of both yeah but it's
usually always really chill yeah run it
around I always take this little
Smashbox brush and I take a bronzer and
I smoke it under the eyes this kind of
just brings the eyeshadow together
pretty low actually and gives you that
smoky look without it being too harsh
because if you do this with an eye
shadow you just look crazy and it'd be
really intense taking that bronzer
really brings it all together
it's subtle but it makes such a big
difference and this is a curling bronzer
actually it's a little kind of almost
like a pinky orange color so I don't
like it as a bronzer I use it as a blush
base they just put it over the cheeks so
when it comes to blush I mix a few just
like my foundation I make it difficult
so I'm taking
this is a Tom Ford one Kevin a Quon
Edward best and then dose of color with
a new minted yeah yeah they're really
pretty so I just take all four of them
and Deb and I always dab a little bit on
my hand first just pop it right on the
cheeks
now highlighters yeah this is the iconic
London these are the little shimmer
drops so it's a liquid and this is the
original color so I take a little bit
just dab a little bit on the back of my
hand and I just take my Beauty Blender
just a quiet all right where you want to
apply your highlighter this is the one -
that really photographs well you know
Chrissy is a highlighter yeah she is a
highlight queen and then I always put a
little bit of the nose and the chin a
little bit on the Cupid's bow so that's
just layer one then I use oh there's a
lot more this is artist couture and it's
called double take and this is a powder
highlight just take a little brush and I
just apply this right over top and this
has a little bit of like a pink to it
mm-hmm
so that's such a pretty color and then
step number three is a Sephora little
highlighters you just write on on the
glow oh yeah and then I dab it with the
Beauty Blender this is the last one how
many have we used so the key to this
look is just highlight I'll a highlight
people always ask what highlight I use
and it's hard it's like wow there's a
few so this one's by Laura Geller and
it's called gilded honey with Christie I
always do more of a nude lip on her and
I'm using oak
Mack I usually switch between oak and
strip-down
both by Mac and I usually like to fill
in the whole lip so the two lipsticks I
usually use are nude cape and this one
is by Marc Jacobs it's number 146 so
usually mix the two together the perfect
nude one lip gloss and just to finish
off the look I'm using this loose
pigment by Mac and it's called vanilla I
just put a little bit right in the inner
corner of the eye and type it on the
nose
[Laughter]
thank you so much for being here Lindsay
for having me so you guys make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to entertainment
tonight's YouTube channel and follow
Lindsay on all of her socials it's
Lindsay Z makeup and let us know in the
comments down below if you guys have any
more questions I will shoot them her way
and also let me know what you guys want
to see next and I will see you in the
next one bye guys
[Music]